écoute Rodolphe essaye de m'envoyer du
rêve en me disant qu'on va se poser sur
la plage alors vu que je suis naïve je
le crois donc on va voir c'est comme ça
Rodolphe impressionne les candidates
aussi voilà si c'est vrai ou pas donc je
ne mens jamais je ne dis pas la vérité
une figure nationale un roublard de la
politique non j'y connaissais pas
grand-chose mais j'avais envie d'en
faire je suis dans la salle j'étais
candidat lors des deux dernières
élections présidentielles le fait que je
sois dans une politique bien sûr
mes filles de moi un vrai dire je passe
les gens parce que je crois que je suis
à l'un des meilleurs compétiteurs donc
en fait je vais me promener à pied
je vais attendre la petite connexion
quoi
le plus intéressant
bon ben voilà il se passe toujours
quelque chose mais
la peine que les gens ont à couper leur
travail quoi ils arrêtent jamais ils
arrêtent jamais ils continuer ça
continue mais moi non non c'est fini moi
là je suis en vacances j'en ai plus rien
à [__] la voix de ses crouler et tout
peut arriver je m'en fous je suis en
vacances un point c'est tout je suis
avec mes enfants et on
profite quoi et bastaques
avec Monique de la compta avec des
connais pas j'en ai rien à [__]
[Rires]
ce truc là on est en vacances conduire
un super beau 4x4 avec des des
personnalités et surtout un personnage
politique
parce que j'allais dire que je connais
une incidité une infidélité à France
Info depuis quasiment 6 mois et c'est un
peu mais c'est un peu de votre faute
parce que franchement j'adore votre
émission vous êtes vraiment un rayon de
soleil franchement quand je vous entends
c'est très varié c'est très relaxant en
plus
sont pour tout le monde en fait et
franchement j'adore
je suis désolé pour mes confrères de
France Info mais c'est pour la bonne
cause c'est ça que je trouve génial tu
continues à être surprise par la vie et
un jour tu as un jour la salle qui
s'endort sur ton époux c'est typique
extérieur on le dit plus parce que c'est
plus l'info mais il crame encore des
bagnoles en France tous les soirs
c'est vrai ça fait pas la une mais il y
a encore des problèmes ça fait plus la
une mais il y a toujours des bagnoles et
le truc est pas circoncis
circonscrit jamais ça aussi ça c'est
j'y arriverai jamais ça braguette et tu
as le droit à un budget
j'étais assez confiant j'avais bien
révisé dit-il il était déjà ravi d'être
d'ores et déjà accepté en licence
d'histoire à la fac de Nancy mais la
semaine dernière en découvrant les
résultats c'est la douche froide il n'a
pas son bac du premier coup il doit
passer par la session de rattrapage il
grappille quelques points on rattrapage
mais pas suffisamment verdict à l'issue
de cette session de rattrapage arrive
obtient la note de 9,99 sur 20 un
sentiment qui ne passe pas
[Applaudissements]
Jean alors Jean cette position quasiment
vers la fin de la ligne pourquoi
mais parce que j'ai pas le salle de bain
de mentir très bien alors je me suis mis
là vous êtes donc vous êtes un mauvais
menteur quoi
ok
fais quoi dans la vie
ce qui reste une bonne nouvelle
on va y aller on va y aller direct
entre nous deux chefs le courant a l'air
de passer tu vas voir que c'est une
partie de plaisir
[Musique]
tu vas vite qui se cache sous ses
cagoules c'est ce que veut savoir le
maire de Saint-Gratien dans le
Val-d'Oise et pour ce faire il demande
aux habitants de sa ville de dénoncer
les fauteurs de troubles il est de la
responsabilité de chacun d'entre vous de
nous communiquer les informations qu'il
possède tant que nous ne posséderons pas
les noms des auteurs des faits aucun
travaux de reconstruction ne sera engagé
[Musique]
obligé pour laisser tomber la tension et
retrouver de l'influx nerveux puis alors
moi si je fais une sieste ça doit c'est
le cas notamment de ce centre culturel
situé dans un quartier sensible la
municipalité ne souhaite pas le
reconstruire pour le moment j'ai trouvé
c'est un bon idée de savoir qui qui a
fait cette chose avant de construire
sans culture
moi je te laisserai ça pendant un
certain temps qu'on le voit et au moins
que les gens le voient pendant un
certain temps qu'on se rappelle c'est
pas la bonne solution parce que les gens
ils vont pas parler se refait au même
point les gens ils vont pas parler les
gens ils ont peur et ça revient au même
point je suis certain que mon parasol va
pas s'envoler et là j'attends que les
autres finissent par s'envoler les uns
après les autres deux amis ont imaginé
ce parasol inspiré par les feuilles
d'arbres il n'offre pas de prise au vent
et il est doté d'une protection anti-UV
son prix 69 euros reste maintenant à se
rafraîchir c'est tongs astucieuse
dispose d'un décapsuleur dans la semelle
t'as pas de pitié pour ta femme j'ai pas
pitié parce que je veux pas être
éliminer non plus
parce que tu as pas envie de compter les
mines donc tu tu sais pas sur qui visait
et tu dis juju tu es traître
c'est beaucoup plus dur que ce que je
pensais on s'était tellement promis avec
Thibault que c'était un jeu en fait je
vis pas bien du tout donc
ouais je crois que c'est le pire rôle à
tenir dans ce jeu
vous allez rire encore non mais 0
commentaire 0 commentaire on pourrait
faire l'amour
bah oui on pourrait ouais
sur le jeu on parle de la chanson bien
sûr ça pourrait être ma fille laisse
tomber on parle de la chanson on
pourrait faire de la petite fille
Célia 25 ans jour pour jour la France a
remporté la Coupe du monde de football
c'était contre le Brésil 3-0 tout le
monde se rappelle donc de ce fameux à 12
juillet 98 et vous quel souvenir vous
avez de cette soirée magique écoutez
deux et trois zéro et puis la la la la
la la la la la
coureur se sont fâchés pour la première
fois depuis la création du Tour de
France ils n'ont pas franchi la ligne
d'arrivée sur leur vélo mais à pied
comme de simples cyclotouristes qui au
terme d'une randonnée cherche le petit
café ils pourront se restaurer les
coureurs d'admettent plus d'être pris
pour de simple pions de vulgaire homme
sandwich il refuse du style de se
coucher à 23h et de se lever le matin à
5h et tout cela uniquement par caprice
et intérêt des organisateurs vous mangez
aussi du bœuf en France oui on en mange
beaucoup
mais vous savez le homard on en mange
deux fois par an voire moins
que c'est très cher en france
ici c'est pas cher non pas du tout c'est
même gratuit ça c'est pas mal mais bon
peut-être que si on mange ça tous les
jours salace